[MUSIC PLAYING]
Data serialization is an important aspect
of every Android application.
But when it comes to performance
there's a right and a wrong way to do it.
My name is Colt McCandless.
And your choice of serialization provider
and format can have a huge impact on
your app's performance.
At its core, serialization is the process
of taking some in-memory object
and converting it
to a formatted chunk of data
that can be converted back
to an in-memory object sometime later.
And serialization is everywhere,
from sending packets
between the server and the Android device,
sending data between two processes,
storing user preferences to disk,
and even simple stuff,
like passing the current song information
to the UI to be displayed.
Typically, most Android developers
will default to the easiest method
to serialize their data.
Namely, extending their class
with the serializable class.
But in terms of performance
you actually couldn't find
a worse solution to the problem.
See, built in classes like
serializable and object output stream
will work great
from a functionality perspective,
but these approaches haves significant
memory and encoding overhead,
making them entirely
too slow for the job at hand.
For the sake of performance,
you're going to want to avoid
all of that chaos, and instead
look at things like the GSON library,
which produces much faster serialization
and more memory-efficient results.
Although there's a large problem with GSON
in that it uses the JSON format,
which is known to produce bloated files.
See, text-based formats like JSON and XML
tend to decode slower and
produce more verbose results.
The problem at hand is that these formats
are human readable.
That means that there's
lots of overly verbose syntax
that's added to the file for
the ease of readability and use.
In addition, these formats
tend to be extremely flexible,
meaning you can make ordering
changes or data changes easily.
But again, that comes at the cost
of needing extra data in the file
that you may not actually
want to send to the user.
By the way, one quick note,
Android resource files,
which are XML formatted, don't
have any of these problems.
They are compiled at build
time into a more compact format
that is more memory
efficient and faster to load.
So you don't need to
worry about any of those.
So when it comes to serialization,
you're going to want a fast codec
that produces the smallest file possible.
And lucky for you, we've got
three great options available.
For starters the Google Protobuffs Library
gets a lot of recognition
for being a very compact,
flexible format for serialization.
Downside though is that
the Java implementation of the library
has significant memory
and code size overhead
which isn't ideal
for mobile development,
which is why the Nano Proto
format was made.
Basically, it's Protobuffs
but optimized for Android development,
so less memory allocations,
a smaller number of method calls
and just less code overhead in general.
But of course, my personal favorite
has to be the Flat Buffers library.
This format was built by one of Google's
game development focused teams
and is focused on performance.
In fact, when it comes to file size,
you can see that Flat
Buffers produce smaller files
than their Protobuff brethren.
And when it comes to
encode and decode times,
flat buffers have a huge advantage.
Their overhead is basically nonexistent.
But the truth is that sometimes,
the most performant solution
is to not use serialization at all!
For example, if you're trying
to store user preferences,
you shouldn't be storing
that as a serialized file.
Instead, try using the
SharedPreferences API.
It's basically a fast key value store
and perfect for this type of data.
Same goes for passing data
between running processes.
Serialization is still
the wrong answer here.
Instead, use the parcelable API,
which gives you
a slightly serialized format
but with a huge performance boost.
And if you've got a lot of structured data
that you plan on serializing, don't!
The overhead of walking
those serialized objects,
not to mention the time
it takes to load them,
is horrible compared to
creating a local database
with a SQL Lite API.
See, everything in performance
is about understanding the caveats
and choosing the best options.
And trust me, caveats are everywhere,
which is why you should watch
the rest of our Android
Performance Patterns videos
And don't forget to join
our Google+ community
to ask questions
to other folks as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember...
Perfmatters!